President Vladimir Putin has accused
Washington of fighting an indirect war
against Russia in Ukraine using
Ukrainian soldiers instead of its own
while the Russian president also
dismissed the Patriot missile defense
system pledged by Washington D.C
regarding Patriot missiles it's a
relatively old system it doesn't work as
well as our s-300 nonetheless those who
were confronting us say this is a
defensive weapon well okay but there
will always be an antidote so the people
who are doing this are doing it in vain
it's just prolonging in the conflict
that's all
well let's speak to Charles Stratford
our correspondent in key let's just talk
about this air defense system and how
the capital is actually preparing to
defend itself over this winter period
well it's very interesting yesterday so
hail we were out filming as part of a
story that we're building on the kind of
air defense efforts that the ukrainians
are making around Kiev and The Wider
country and what we saw was an
incredible level of organization and
enthusiasm but certainly a multi-layered
system and we were given access to what
the ukrainians describe as mobile air
defense systems and what struck us the
most was the age of some of the weapons
that they were using mainly heavy
machine guns some uh bolted onto the
back of trucks this particular unit was
basically part so they say of a wider
network and on receiving alerts of an
imminent attack by some of these uh
these Kamikaze drones and cruise
missiles then they'd be able to track
these drones approaching at least not
the crews there's no way that a heavy
machine gun can take it down a cruise
missile
um to follow these drones and take them
down we know that the ukrainians have
been very successful by and large in
intercepting many of these Kamikaze
drones and cruise missiles but we also
know that it's had these bombardments
have had a devastating attack results
consequences on the kind of energy
infrastructure here there are millions
of people still across Kiev at the cave
region and The Wider country who are
enduring rolling blackouts and heating
problems because the authorities cannot
get electricity to them on a 24-hour
basis and in the last 24 hours or so
Ukraine's energy Minister has said that
they're not going to be able to restore
the full capacity a full working order
of Ukraine's electrical grid system
until the summer and we are fully
expecting more attacks by the Russians
targeting this infrastructure now of
course as we know there have been big
big contributions more contributions by
Western countries in recent recent days
and weeks most notably from the
Americans to try and bolster these air
defenses when in fact those kind of
systems will arrive and of course the
complexities of training ukrainians to
use them it's um it's debatable
um and and it's a big question as to
when they are going to be ready to be
used so the situation here is still in
crisis mode as I say with a prospect any
time of more attacks of course it's one
of the many concerns uh that Keith has
at the moment Charles so just bring us
up to speed on what we know in terms of
what's going on around bakmut at the
moment
yes so that city buckmut a city that the
ukrainians now are calling a meat
grinder because of the intensity of the
fighting there an incredible war of
trade of attrition
um we know that buckmouth has been
fought over intensely for the last few
months we also know that the Russians
have made very little gains there but
certainly the Ukrainian military
authorities are saying that on a daily
basis they're getting probing attacks
from the Russians from the North and the
South of bakmut as they try and encircle
the city we've seen incredible footage
of close uh close combat Street by
street fighting trench warfare we know
that the Russians are using artillery
they're using heavy mortars and air
strikes in order to try and push forward
in the city the reason why is important
is because military analysts will tell
you that it would give Russians a
clearer path to attacking the two
largest cities still in Ukrainian
control in the donets region those
cities of crematores and sloviansk it's
safe to say though that since those big
gains were made by the ukrainians in a
counter-offensive in September and
October it has reached a bit of a
stalemate in that area and of course
that comes at a time when the Ukrainian
military establishment are very
concerned about what they describe as a
potential winter offensive being planned
by Russia
um just some some information also from
an area along the Donetsk and lugansk
Regional borders that's north of that
city of bahmoud this is an area that we
visited a couple of months ago a town
called tors gay which was a new front
line in that area close to a town called
cremina which the Russians control now
the ukrainians took control of tour
scares as I say a couple of months ago
the Ukrainian authorities now are
claiming that they have liberated a
couple more Villages north of tulski so
we also know that our intense fighting
along the borders of Donetsk and lugansk
Charles Stratford Falls there in Keith
thanks Charles